MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
and welcome to Talks at Google.
Today we're joined by Arlene
Blum, celebrated aplinist
and biophysical chemist.
As a mountaineer, she led
the first all-female ascent
of Annapurna, one of the
14 8,000-meter peaks.
On Denali, she co-led the
first women's team climb.
She was the first American
woman to attempt Mount Everest
and completed the great
Himalayan Traverse
across Bhutan, Nepal, and India.
As a scientist, she's worked
as a tireless advocate
for consumer safety.
Her research has focused on
the use of toxic chemicals
in everyday products.
This work has led to bans on
carcinogenic flame retardants
in children's sleepwear
and household furniture.
Currently, she serves as
Executive Director of the Green
Science Policy Institute
and is a visiting scholar
at UC Berkeley's
Department of Chemistry.
Today, she will share stories
of climbing and policy
from her memoir, "Breaking
Trail: A Climbing Life."
Please join me in
welcoming Arlene Blum.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it's really great
to be here sharing
adventures in both science
and mountain climbing.
Because I suspect many of
you have your own adventures
in things relating to
science, and it probably
feels like mountain climbing.
Some of you might
be looking at me
and thinking that I seem
like a regular person,
and how did I start doing
all those crazy things.
So I will start back
where it all started.
That's my freshman chemistry
lab at Reed College.
And my chemistry professor
was a young woman.
She was 23.
She had a Ph.D. From MIT
and thought chemistry
was the neatest
subject on the planet.
There were four
girls in my class,
and we all got
doctorates in chemistry,
which says something about
the importance of role models.
Also, my chemistry lab partner
was a very handsome young man
from Portland who was
a mountain climber.
And late one starry
night, he said,
do you want to go
climb Mount Hood?
And he was very
handsome, so I said sure.
And we drove up to
Timberline Lodge,
and he put a big
pack on my back.
I was from Chicago.
I'd never done anything
very physical in my life.
I started gasping.
He later said he didn't
think I'd make it out
of the parking lot.
But he was very handsome.
I was very determined.
And we got up on the snow.
It was the most
beautiful place I'd been.
I fell in love with him
and with mountain climbing,
and started a life of
mountains and molecules--
or we said peaks, public
policy, and public health.
So I continue doing expeditions.
Back in those days, the
world's highest mountains
had not been climbed
much by women.
And indeed, when I applied
to go on an expedition
to Denali, the highest
mountain in North America,
I was told that
women didn't have
the physical strength
or emotional stability
to climb mountains like Denali.
So this is the first all women's
expedition on top of Denali,
which I took the picture,
so I'm not in it.
And so I continued doing
mountains and molecules.
And then things really changed
on this beautiful mountain
in India.
Now, doesn't this look like
an easy, beautiful mountain?
Wouldn't you all
like to be there?
It's nearly 24,000 feet,
but it's gentle snow slopes.
And we're climbing
this mountain,
and got up to near the top.
It was our summit day.
And I'm kind of a slow
climber, so the others
got to the top first.
And when I got to
the top, someone
said, what happened to Bruce,
who had gotten there first?
And Bruce had walked along
here to what was here,
which was snow, but was
actually a cornice where
the snow is over a rock face.
And the cornice broke,
and he fell to his death.
And Bruce was the country's
leading young rock climber.
He had pioneered the
hardest routes in Yosemite
without using pitons.
And it was just
unbelievable that he
died on this easy but
high mountain in India.
So when that happened,
I got very depressed.
At the time, I was a
postdoc at Stanford
studying how proteins fold.
And that seemed
really irrelevant.
And I wanted to do something
for the environment
in Bruce's memory.
And so I went to a
professor of mine
at Berkeley, [INAUDIBLE]
Committee, Bruce Aimes,
and said, is there anything I
can do to help the environment?
And he said, well, why don't
you look at the flame retardants
in children's sleepwear?
He said, right now, pretty
much all the kids in America
are wearing pajamas that are
10% by weight a flame retardant
called brominated tris.
And I think it might get from
the pajamas into the children,
and it's a cancer-causing
chemical, I think.
And so that seemed a little
weird to me, flame retardants.
But I was depressed, so I
thought I want to do something.
So I found a little
girl who had never
worn tris-treated pajamas.
And we put her in the pajamas
and collected her urine.
And the first morning
she wore them,
she had tris products
in her urine.
And she wore them
for three days.
The level of tris in
her urine went up,
and she stopped wearing
them, and it went down.
So it meant the tris was
getting into the little girl.
And then we ran a screening test
to see if tris was a mutagen.
Did it change DNA?
And it was one of the strongest
mutagens ever studied.
So this was a huge worry.
And we thought, oh my goodness.
We need to tell the
parents of America
that most of the
kids in the country
are wearing pajamas
that are 10% by weight
this harmful chemical.
So about that time, I got
invited to go to this mountain.
Do you know what
mountain this is?
Anybody know?
Mount Everest.
It's the highest
mountain in the world.
And at that point,
no American woman
had ever even had a chance to
try to climb Mount Everest.
So I was like, wow, this
is such an opportunity.
And I didn't know what to do.
Should I stay and
write the paper
about the tris-treated
pajamas, or should I
go try to climb Mount Everest?
So I can't help but ask.
How many of you would
have stayed and written
the paper about the
tris-treated pajamas?
Most of you.
How many of you would have
gone to Mount Everest?
Even more.
Well, I did both.
So I did go to Mount Everest.
And when I was climbing
in the Khumbu Icefall,
every night, I'd
write the paper.
And then up in the
great Western Cwm,
we'd put stringing
ladders, and making
our way amongst the
crevasses, and we'd
get up steep ice faces.
And every night, I'd
keep working on the paper
until I reached my high point.
Here I am at about
24 5 on Everest.
And my summit flag, The
Mutants, has a Petri dish.
Without tris, there
are only two colonies,
because it's a mutagen.
And this one you can see.
It's blowing in the wind.
That's the tris Petri dish
with many bacterial colonies.
So this was October of 1976.
And we did reach the summit.
We were the second
American expedition.
Now people reach the
summit all the time.
But the first American
expedition was '63,
and we were the
second one in '76,
so it was much less [INAUDIBLE].
And we had the whole
mountain to ourselves.
Only one expedition on Mount
Everest, which is a little bit
different nowadays.
So I finished the paper.
I sent it by mail
runner to Kathmandu.
And it was published in Science
Magazine a couple months later.
And if you read the
subtitle of the paper,
the main flame retardant in
children's pajamas is a mutagen
and should not be used.
Now, that's a little bit of
an unusual title for a paper.
If any of you--
I'm sure you have--
if you read scientific
papers, they
tend to have the
same recommendation
at the end, almost invariably.
And what's that
recommendation at the end
of all scientific papers?
What is the next step?
More studies.
And it's always more studies.
And it tends not to be something
like a chemical should not
be used in kids' pajamas.
And at the Green Science
Policy Institute,
our goal is to really help
inspire, encourage scientists
to take their research and tell
people what needs to be done.
Because scientists are
the ones who really know.
They understand the
science, and then they
understand what
needs to be done.
And we believe that scientists
have a responsibility
to share their science in
a way that affects change,
particularly if they're
working on harmful chemicals.
And it works.
Scientists are very respected.
When they speak
up, things happen.
This was January
of 1977 where we
called for tris not being
used in kid's pajamas.
And April 1977, tris was
banned from kid's pajamas,
just like it should be.
And that was a
really good thing,
because whole generations
of kids only wore it.
It was only used for
a couple of years,
which is a very good thing.
So however, when a
chemical is banned,
there's a big
tendency to replace it
with another chemical that's
very similar, because industry
likes to keep processes
as similar as possible.
It makes sense.
It was funny.
I remember about six
months after the tris ban,
I thought, I wonder
what they're using now,
if they're still using tris.
So I remember I rode I rode my
bicycle to Penny's, downtown
Berkeley, and I bought
20 pairs of pajamas
in all different sizes.
And the sales lady
just gushed at me,
oh, you have such
a nice, big family.
And I sort of felt like a
super spy with all my pajamas.
And I thought, well, these
might make nice shower presents
for my friends.
So I just took a
little fabric out
of the inseam of each pajama.
But I actually didn't need
to bother, since none of them
would I have wanted
to give for presents.
And then I analyzed
what was in them.
And not surprisingly,
about a third of them
had brominated interest,
because it takes time
for the market to turn over.
But then nearly 2/3 of
them had a new chemical
which turned out to be
chlorinated tris, almost
identical.
And so we went, oh my god.
So we ran more
immunogenicity tests,
and chlorinated tris was also
a mutagen. It changed DNA.
And we wrote another
paper in Science,
and chlorinated tris was
removed from pajamas.
However, what we
didn't know then
is it continued to be used,
for example, in furniture.
And in 2005, when a
very bad flame retardant
was banned from use
in our furniture,
it was replaced with
chlorinated tris,
which was then banned in 2012.
But if any of you
have a couch that
was purchased between
2006 and 2012--
anyone have a couch
purchased during that time?
Anyway, there's about a 3/4
chance that your couch-- 5%
of the weight of the foam
will be chlorinated tris.
So if you have 20 pounds
of foam in your couch,
you have about a pound of
this chemical in your couch.
Not the best.
But we didn't know it back then.
And back then, I thought
it was really time
to give women a chance to climb
one of the world's highest
mountains.
So in the '70s, all the
world's 8,000-meter peaks--
there are 14 of them.
The highest mountains in the
world had been climbed by men,
and no woman had
climbed that high.
And I thought, women
should have a chance.
We had done pretty
well on Everest.
So I got a permit for Annapurna
on my way back from Everest,
and I thought, it's the first
of the 8,000-meter peaks ever
climbed, among the lowest.
It must be one of the
safest and easiest.
But as it turned out,
there wasn't so much
research in those days.
So guess which is the
most dangerous of all
the 8,000-meter peaks?
Annapurna.
And which has the
highest fatality rate
and is considered, perhaps,
the most difficult to climb?
Anyway, we didn't know that.
But we found out.
So this is our team.
We had 10 climbers, a couple
filmmakers, a base camp
manager.
We're all still friends.
There are copies
here afterwards-- I'm
happy to sign copies of
"Annapurna" or "Breaking
Trail" for people.
And "Annapurna" has just
been reprinted, September 15.
Sierra Club Books had
been out of business,
and the book had been out
of press for a few years,
so it's just back in press.
And we're all
going to be getting
together for an Annapurna
book party next month.
And I have to say,
when we get together,
it feels like we're
back on the glacier
just like it did
a long time ago.
So climbing Annapurna
was incredibly beautiful.
I'll just share a
few of the pictures.
The beauty is extraordinary, but
the climbing was really tough.
And there were huge storms.
The reason it's such
a dangerous mountain
is very high precipitation.
And these huge snowfalls
led to huge avalanches.
So it was a very
dangerous place.
Ever since I became a mom, I
haven't wanted to go there.
But wonderful climbing.
And we did reach the summit.
We were the first women,
the first Americans.
We reached the summit
with two Sherpa climbers.
We unfurled our flags,
held together with a Save
the Whales pin, and
we felt content then
we had achieved our goal.
But we tragically
lost two of our team
on a second summit attempt.
So climbing Annapurna is a
very, very dangerous thing.
I wrote this book,
"Annapurna: A Woman's Place,"
which now, as I said, it's
just been reissued this week.
And then I wrote another
book, "Breaking Trail,"
trying to understand how
my childhood and my life
had led to both my scientific
research and my mountain
climbing.
And when I finished "Breaking
Trail," it was in 2006.
I had spent 20 years
writing "Breaking Trail."
I twas like a personal
therapy project.
It was a lot of work trying
to understand my family.
And I had just
finished the book.
My daughter was
starting college.
I thought I'd really would like
to go back to doing science.
But I actually stopped
being a scientist in 1980
to walk across the whole
Himalayan mountain range.
I have a job at UC Berkeley.
I said, I want to
take a year off
to walk across the Himalayas.
And they were like,
well, you have to decide.
Do you want your chemistry
job or the Himalayas?
So I chose the
Himalayas in 1980.
And many things intervened.
It was 2006, 26 years later.
And the last sentence
of "Breaking Trail"
is the future is like
an unbroken snow slope.
I hope I can find a way to
break trail to a better world.
But I actually really didn't
know what I was going to do,
because we hadn't done
science for 26 years.
I thought, well, maybe
I can get a job washing
test tubes in a lab.
I thought I must be
completely out of date.
But that was nine years ago.
And the last nine years,
I have felt every day
like I was climbing Annapurna.
I've been on my life's
greatest adventure.
And it's been really
similar, because we're
working with a great team of
scientists and businesspeople
all over the world.
A bunch of people in Google
are on the same team.
Really working together for
healthier and safer products.
And it's a real challenge,
but a real opportunity.
So I felt incredibly
lucky that I could not
do science for 26 years and then
come back and be able to really
try to climb this mountain.
And the reason that we're
all climbing this mountain
is there is a big problem.
And that is-- I sometimes
ask this question.
I bet you'll know the answer.
But what do you
think-- do you think
if you have chemicals
in your shampoo
or your toothpaste
or your chair,
anyone think the government
is making sure they're
safe for their your health?
You all know not.
But most people do think that.
I used to think that.
And the government actually
can't, because they
don't have the authority.
There's only one
law about chemicals
before they go out in the world.
Once they're out
in the world, you
have a Clean Air Act,
a Clean Water Act,
but you can't really
bring them back in.
So the only law before
they go out in the world
is called the Toxic
Substances Control Act.
It passed in 1976.
62,000 chemicals were
grandfathered, like you're OK.
And even a chemical like
asbestos that kills 10,000
people a year cannot be
controlled by the EPA.
And you might say asbestos,
there are asbestos lawsuits.
Asbestos is illegal.
Well, asbestos is not illegal.
There are lawsuits.
And there's a rare
form of cancer
called mesothelioma
that's only associated
with asbestos exposure.
So if you're an asbestos worker
or the spouse of an asbestos
worker and you get
mesothelioma, you
can sue the asbestos
industry that that's
the reason for your disease.
And you'll probably win the
case, but you also will die.
Everybody that gets
mesothelioma dies.
And that's not a good way
to regulate chemicals.
And that's how we regulate
asbestos, through lawsuits.
By then, it's really late.
So the 62,000 chemicals
nobody can do anything
about-- there have been 20,000
new industrial chemicals.
No data is required.
Most of them have
no health data.
2/3 have no data at all.
The EPA has six weeks to try
to show harm with no data.
And if they do show
harm, the company
has several years to try to
prove their chemical is OK,
and they can sell it
during those several years
to raise the money
for the testing.
And once they're out
there selling it,
it's really hard to stop it.
So basically-- and
indeed, I'm going
to speak at the EPA tomorrow.
In fact, if anyone
wants to hear my talk,
you can tell them
10 o'clock tomorrow,
I'll be speaking by the
post office at the main EPA
building.
So if you ASK the EPA, they
say we can't even ban asbestos.
They say that.
It's really a problem.
Another problem--
and in fact, this
leads to what two brilliant
pediatricians, Herb Needleman
and Phil Landrigan, said--
that we are de facto conducting
a human toxicological trial.
Our children and our
children's children
are the experimental subjects.
So if these chemicals aren't
tested in any other way,
they're tested on us.
And that's not a
good thing to do.
And they do contribute
to increased rates
of cancer, infertility,
neurological impairments.
So another problem
is what we call
the regrettable
substitution problem.
If after a lot of work,
a chemical is regulated,
the substitute is often
the chemical cousin.
For example, over here, we
have-- if you know chemistry,
we've got decabromo,
10 bromines, diphenly,
two phenyl rings.
Decabrominated
diphenyl ether, that's
an ether bond with the
oxygen in the middle.
And it's persistent,
bioaccumulative, and toxic.
And about 15% of the weight to
the plastic in an average TV
is decabromodiphenyl ether.
It's used in fabric back
coatings, many uses.
Due to its severe persistence,
bioaccumulation and toxicity,
the deca ether has
been phased out.
But what's the substitute?
Decabrominated diphenyl ethane.
So there's an ethane
bond instead of an ether.
It's also persistent,
bioaccumulative,
and appears to be toxic.
So as the deca
ether sales go down,
the deca ethane sales go up.
Is that a good deal?
Not much improvement.
So it's a discouraging
situation.
However-- everyone is looking
depressed but me, right?
Because I think there are
things that can be done.
And to solve this
problem, we decided
to bring together scientists who
cared passionately about this
to really focus on
what could be done.
And so we have had
a series of retreats
where we invite five
scientists from industry,
five from academia, five from
NGOs, and five from government.
So it's about 20
scientists, maybe 25.
And at the first retreat,
we said, are there
certain chemicals,
certain chemical families,
that we know are harmful
that can be avoided?
A simpler way of
thinking of this.
When you think of
that 80,000 chemicals,
it sounds kind of daunting.
All you can do is put your
head down and get poison.
Because who can deal
with 80,000 chemicals?
So we came up with six classes.
And this is a solution
that really invites action.
And so briefly, the classes are
highly fluorinated chemicals.
These are stain and water
repellents, like Scotchguard.
Let me just ask-- how
many of you knew or know--
and by the way,
there's a handout
at the back when you leave that
lists all the classes and more
information about them.
But let me see.
How many of you know
that Scotchguard is
a problem in these chemicals?
OK.
One person who
works in this area.
But when people know, they
can make better choices.
The next class is the
chlorinated antimicrobials,
like triclosan and triclocarban
approach ban liquids soaps.
Who knew about them?
A couple people.
Then we have the
flame retardants.
Who's heard about
the flame retardants?
OK.
You've all heard about
the flame retardants.
We have bisphenols.
Remember those bisphenol
A water bottles?
Phthalates, organic
solvents, certain metals.
And you look at
this list-- this is
most of the harmful chemicals
in everyday products.
And when you know they're there
and you know what they are,
you can make safe choices
and avoid their use.
And even more than
that, we want to ask
if they're in that class, is
this chemical really necessary?
So if the chemical that makes
a carpet stain repellent
is a highly fluorinated
chemical that's quite toxic
and never breaks down
for geologic time,
maybe if you say
to a mom, you can
have a stain-repellent
carpet, but the chemical
is going into your
baby's body and staying,
what would the mom say?
Maybe she might say,
it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
So I believe just asking
these questions-- do
we really need it?
Is it necessary?
You can stop the use of a
big chunk of these chemicals,
really reduce their use.
And then if you think
they're necessary
and they're worth it, then say,
is there a safer alternative
and really invest in
that safer alternative.
So we've heard about green
chemistry for a very long time.
It's been around for 20 years.
A classic book was written
by John Warner, who's here
in Boston, and Paul Anastas.
And it's a great idea.
Everybody loves it.
But it's not happening
as much as it should.
And so if a kind of
function is needed
and you really
want that function,
then invest in green chemistry,
not in moving to the chemical
cousin.
We have a webinar serious
about these six classes.
They're 15-minute webinars.
There's a flier in the back.
And when we played the webinar
series and we ran them live,
about 1,200 people signed up.
And they were from many of the
retailers and manufacturers
across the country.
And amazing things happened.
There was a webinar
on antimicrobials,
and after it was on, someone
some Target called and said,
we had no idea that we had
triclosan in our personal care
line, and we're taking it out.
And they just took
it out right away.
So companies can
do that overnight.
For government, it's
much, much harder.
So if you want to
learn more, you
can listen to this
webinar series.
Purchasers are key.
Manufacturers of
consumer products
can just stop using
toxics in their products,
and that is starting to happen.
Large retailers
can say, we're not
going to sell-- IKEA
is our leading example.
IKEA has said no more
fluorinated chemicals.
Almost all the six
classes IKEA is not
putting in any of
their products,
which is really inspiring.
And then corporate
big buyers can say,
we're not going to
purchase products
with these harmful
classes of chemicals.
And consumers-- consumers
is a hard group to reach.
They get many messages.
They're pretty busy.
So we prefer to work
with some of the larger
purchasers and manufacturers.
And the actions
for manufacturers
is to come together and
say, we want disclosure.
We want to know what's
in our products.
And then we want to really ask
if harmful chemicals are needed
and ask for products
without them.
And if that's not possible,
invest in green chemistry.
So a very cool thing is
there's a Buyer's Club out
in California, and
Google is a member along
with Kaiser and Facebook
and all these companies.
And they've all come together
with their tens of billions
of dollars of collective
purchasing power to say,
we want transparency
for manufacturers.
We want to know
what's in products.
And then we're going to come
together and buy safer products
with less toxics.
And that's really exciting.
I know I just spoke at
Harvard earlier today,
and Harvard says they want to
organize a Buyer's Club here
in the Northeast
and see if they can
get MIT and other
educational institutions.
Oberlin is talking about
trying to organize one
in the Midwest with a lot
of the small schools there.
So buyers clubs can
be really powerful
and can really move the market.
Here's Harvard saying
they want to make
a buyer's club targeting
harmful chemicals on campus.
So we're going to talk now
about flame retardants.
That's how I started
doing all this.
And the reason they're
there is back in the '70s,
standards were made for
products-- children sleepwear,
furniture, foam plastic
building insulation.
And these standards led to
the use of flame retardants.
And nobody asked
if the standards
provided a fire safety
benefit or asked
about the harm of the chemicals.
And with flame retardants,
the only way to change things
is to change standards.
Changing the chemicals
doesn't work.
There's always a
chemical cousin.
But if the standards change,
then you no longer need them.
Back to people's couches.
Several of you bought your
couches between 2005 and 2012,
and you have chlorinated
tris, the same chemical that
was removed from kid's pajamas.
And the reason is a
California standard
called Technical Bulletin 117.
If you go home, you lift the
center cushion of your couch,
you'll probably see a
label that says TB 117.
And this is not a very
effective standard.
It requires the foam
inside the furniture
to resist a very small
flame for 12 seconds.
So if you think about
that, what happens if you
drop a candle on your couch?
What burns first?
The fabric.
And when the fabric burns,
you have a large flame,
and then the foam burns
in two or three seconds.
And when foam is treated with
flame retardants and it burns,
it gives off a lot more
smoke and toxic gases.
And what kills people
in fires is soot, smoke,
and toxic gases.
And so Technical Bulletin 117
has been around since 1975,
and there's no data to show that
it's provided any fire safety.
But it has instead ended up
that the toxic flame retardant
chemicals are in most
Americans' bodies.
So if you bought your
couch before 2004-- anybody
have a couch from before 2004?
OK.
Well, those are worse.
Because they all have a
very harmful chemical--
pentabrominated diphenyl
ether, a big mouthful.
But the top picture up there
is polybrominated biphenyl,
a PBB or PCB.
Those are toxic.
They're persistent.
PCBs are not good molecules.
If instead of having
a covalent bond,
you have an ether bond
between your rings,
then you have a
polybrominated biphenyl ether.
And if you burn or oxidize,
that becomes another ether bond.
This is a dioxin and a furan.
So this is the
flame retardant that
was used from 1975 until
2004 to meet TB 117.
It's halfway in structure
between a dioxin and a PCB.
Not a great molecule to have
in your home, in your dust,
in your body.
And in fact, we had a group
of Berkeley summer students
studying chemistry
and policy at Berkeley
collecting [INAUDIBLE] samples
and getting them analyzed.
And one of the professors
said, the students
should not touch that
PBDE flame retardant
except wearing full
gear and a fume hood.
And I'm like, but it's
in everybody's furniture.
So that is an unfortunate thing.
And almost all the
use of the chemical
has been in North
America, in large part
to meet this standard.
But it has traveled the
world, this global pollutant.
So when we make these sorts of
chemicals, they go all over.
There are hundreds of
animal studies showing
neurological and reproductive
harm from the penta chemical.
And about two weeks
ago, studies were
finalized showing it
indeed does cause cancer.
In humans, if pregnant
women have higher levels,
it takes them longer
to become pregnant.
And during critical windows
of brain development,
their thyroid hormones are
altered so that their children
will have lower birth
rate, impaired attention,
poor coordination,
and lowered IQ.
So the average California child
has lost four to five IQ points
just from this flame
retardant penta.
An economist
calculated a $9 billion
loss in earning power in
California children due to IQ
loss from penta, which is
one of the many, many harms
from this chemical.
So how does the
chemical end up in us?
It's a semi-volatile
organic chemical, an SVOC.
So it's continually
coming out of furniture,
dropping into dust.
And if eat a sandwich, you
have some dust on your fingers,
you eat a little bit
of dust, the penta
ends up inside of you.
Children, toddlers
who crawl on the dust,
put their hands in
their mouth, tend
to have three to
five times higher
levels than their parents,
which is not a good thing.
And cats have up to
100 times higher level
compared to humans.
Why would cats have
such a high level?
Because of their
grooming behavior.
So as I said, no fire safety
benefit, serious harm.
We came to realize that
TB 117, the standard
could be changed to a
fabric standard that
could be met without flame
retardants that would
stop the fire in the fabric.
So there didn't need to
be any flame retardants,
and you could have
increased fire safety.
Does that sound
like a good idea?
So we had a bill with Senator
Mark Leno out there in front.
And our bill was supported
by the furniture industry,
who didn't like putting
toxics in their furniture.
Foam industry, fabric
industry, firefighters
supported it, because they knew
the flame retardants didn't
help and could cause cancer.
Everybody supported it.
But these bills never passed.
And the reason was
Californians for Fire Safety.
And this is part of a
one-week-long, $7 million
advertising campaign.
One of the bills almost passed.
And they were very
determined, I believe,
to keep their market share
in selling flame retardants.
And the legislators
tended to vote
for Californians for Fire
Safety rather than business,
firefighters, scientists,
and the public.
And this went on
for about six years.
And I'd go to hearings where
the lobbyists for the flame
retardant industry
would be saying
it's not sound
science to say there's
harm from any flame retardants.
They've all been
evaluated by the EPA.
Evaluated?
What did they find?
They don't say that part.
So we decided to put
together all the science.
And in a big meeting
in San Antonio,
we developed the San
Antonio Statement.
It was signed by a
couple scientists.
It documented the harm
and the lack of benefit
of the flame retardants.
And it was published
in Environmental Health
Perspectives back in 2010.
And still, nothing
much happened.
I would joke-- when
I went to parties,
people would ask me
what I did, and I'd
start telling the whole story
of the toxic flame retardants
in everybody's
furniture, no benefit.
They'd get all wound up, and
after a while, they'd go,
I have to leave now.
And I'd see them on the other
side of the room talking
to someone else.
And I thought, oh my goodness.
Am I going to
spend my whole life
being this woman who rants at
parties about flame retardants?
I started to feel a
little crackpot-ish.
And then things changed
when the Chicago Tribune--
I had pitched this to
many, many reporters,
but the Chicago Tribune
did a fantastic job.
This is the first front page.
The headline-- a deceptive
campaign by industry
brought toxic flame
retardants into our homes
and into our bodies,
and the chemicals
didn't even work as promised.
And this story documents-- all
these hearings I'd been to,
there was always
this burn doctor
who had won the Dalai
Lama Compassion Award.
And he was always talking
about some poor, burned baby.
It was this horrific
death this baby had, all
because there were no flame
retardants in her crib.
And it was horrible.
And it never really
connected to what
the subject of the
legislation was.
It made no sense.
But he would do it,
and then everybody
would be very
emotional, and it would
give the legislators
cover to vote no
on these new standards that
would increase fire safety.
And so these reporters
researched the hearings,
and they listened
to four times he
talked about the burned baby.
And they realized they
were all different.
And then they confronted
him, and he said,
well, really, I was
just kind of talking.
But there was a baby.
And he gave them a
picture of a baby.
And they tracked it
down, and this baby
died for a completely
different reason.
And the mother was
really unhappy.
And the doctor said, well, we're
not under oath in California,
so I can say what I want.
And ultimately, it
was learned that he
was paid $240,00
for his testimony,
and he stopped being a doctor.
So a real scandal
in these series.
If you want to read them, you
can read "Playing With Fire."
They came in second
for the Pulitzer.
They won all these
environmental awards.
And everything changed.
So instead of me being this
person at parties ranting,
suddenly, Dick Durbin was
ranting in the Senate.
There were hearings
in the Senate.
This really empowered
Jerry Brown, our governor.
That series came
out in May, 2012.
A month later, Jerry Brown
directed the state agencies
to revise our standards so that
we could reduce and eliminate
dangerous flame retardants and
at the same time increase fire
safety.
So this made a huge difference.
And thanks to this, we
now have a new standard.
You can go out and buy a
couch that meets TB 117-2013.
And as you see, your couch
will have a label on it.
And it says either
contains flame retardants
or contains no flame retardants.
So you can have that choice.
Foam plastic building
insulation-- unfortunately,
the materials that
make buildings energy
efficient-- polystyrene,
polyurethane,
and polyisocyanurate contain
the worst flame retardants,
and there's no benefit.
You think about foam below
the cement, below the grade
down there, it has
flame retardants.
There's no oxygen.
There's no fuel source.
And nonetheless, flame
retardants are required.
So we now-- and
it's really hard--
have been trying to change
the international building
code to allow foam plastic
without flame retardants
where there is no
fire safety benefit.
The big hearing is September 30.
And it's really a struggle,
because the same three
companies who make
the flame retardants
are adamantly
wanting to keep them
in our building installation.
If you want to reduce your
own flame retardant exposure,
it's not a bad time
to buy new furniture
or to swap out the foam in
your furniture for safer foam
or else to vacuum with
a HEPA filter, well mop,
and hand wash.
It all reduces exposure to dust.
So I'm going to go now through
the rest of the classes
much more quickly.
Highly fluorinated
chemicals, I think,
are the worst of the worst.
The carbon fluorine
bond is the strongest
in the periodic table.
It really does not
break for geologic time.
So this class of chemicals are
very oil and water repellent,
but they never break down.
They just accumulate
on the planet.
And the chemical
that was mostly used
was something called PFOA
or C8-- 8 carbons surrounded
by fluorines.
And this is a book--
"Stain Resistant, Nonstick,
Waterproof, and Lethal:
the Hidden Dangers of C8."
And it's very interesting,
because it tells
the story of the harm of C8.
What happened was that C8 was
used in the making of Teflon.
DuPont dumped the C8
in the water supplies
in communities in Ohio
and West Virginia.
People got sick.
They sued.
They measured the
levels in thousands
of people who had
a very high level,
and then they looked
at health effects.
And among those people--
this is, again, human health
effects-- they
found higher levels
of two kinds of cancer,
cholesterol, thyroid disease,
all those health conditions.
And those people sued DuPont.
And the first hearing was today.
So this happened
a long time ago.
Today is the first lawsuit.
I read about it.
And DuPont had known since
the '60s about the harm of C8.
They had been monitoring
the water supply,
knew it was in the water.
But they claimed that the
levels, they didn't think,
were that high.
And they said and if
the chemical had really
been harmful, the government
would have regulated it.
That was their argument.
So we'll see what happens
with these trials.
But DuPont has actually
spun off all this liability.
They have a new company called
Chemours that has the liability
and makes these chemicals.
So it's not clear what
the outcome will be.
But you can follow it online.
Where are these chemicals found?
Food contact paper.
If paper is oil and
grease resistant,
like pizza boxes,
microwave popcorn bags,
it very likely has highly
fluorinated chemicals.
Cosmetics-- not many cosmetics,
but several thousand of them
do contain
fluorinated chemicals.
It will say fluoride
on the package.
Outdoor equipment, carpets,
clothing, furniture.
And so C8 has been
phased out in 2015.
It took 50 years from when
the harm was first discovered.
And what is the
replacement for C8?
C6-- six carbons with
fluorines all around.
It's equally persistent.
It doesn't break down
for geologic time.
That's millions of years,
possibly longer than humanity.
And the world is
filling up with it.
There's nowhere for it to go.
It's in water, increasing
levels in human blood.
Philip [INAUDIBLE], a professor
at Harvard who studies it,
says it seems to
accumulate in the brain.
And do we really want
C8 in our brains?
So we did a Madrid Statement on
highly fluorinated chemicals.
It was signed by 230
scientists, published last May
1 in Environmental
Health Perspectives.
Nobody much had heard
about these chemicals.
They, I always say, did
not get the attention
they had deserved.
So we document the
potential for harm,
a roadmap to prevent
further harm.
And it got a lot of press.
Nick Kristof wrote about
chemicals in your popcorn.
National Geographic,
these chemicals
in pizza boxes and
carpeting last forever.
My favorite massive
group of scientists
thinks you shouldn't use
nonstick from Modern Farmer.
But there were
hundreds of press hits.
And the world is slowly starting
to find out about nonstick.
A lot of brands
are eliminating it,
starting with H&M.
Levi's has phased it out.
Now, these brands
don't talk about it.
Because if they say,
well, your new products
don't have this
toxic chemical, what
does that say about
your old products?
So they don't tend to advertise
it, but it is happening.
This is in the public domain
that all these companies
are phasing it out.
What can be done?
Google really wants safe
buildings for their employees,
and they're very active in
working for transparency.
And they're part of
the Buyer's Club.
And we're working with the
Buyer's Club in California
to give them lists of
products with and without
fluorinated chemicals.
This is from a
database called Pharos,
but there's a lot more
chemicals than this.
So if you want any
of these products,
you can pick the
ones with and without
the fluorinated chemicals.
And the hope is to really move
the market towards without.
When people know the extent
of the harm and the fact--
the chemical industry is
saying C6 is perfectly fine,
but there are 40 forms of C6.
We took 50 years to ban it, one
form of [INAUDIBLE] not ban,
phase out.
So with 40 forms of C6, it's
just not going to happen.
But purchasers can
move to safer products.
So all these products can
contain fluorinated chemicals.
So try not to buy nonstick
if you can avoid it.
The last class I'm going to
talk about in some detail
is the chlorinated
antimicrobials.
That's triclosan
and triclocarban.
They're used, for
example, in liquid soaps.
It turns out the
best thing to wash
your hands is soap and water.
Having bacteria on your
hands is a good thing.
Triclosan kills
all the bacteria.
I've heard people say, well,
maybe in a hospital setting,
it's useful.
But Kaiser has banned it
at about six years ago.
Now, Purell-- alcohol is fine.
It's tricolosan, the
antimicrobial, triclocarban.
And it's really sad, but
the FDA-- in 1974, the FDA
wrote a monograph on the
lack of efficacy and safety
of triclosan, and that
report still has not
been finalized and published.
Meanwhile, back in '94,
there was a handful
of uses for antimicrobials,
because they were
considered pharmaceuticals.
And they removed
from that category,
and now there's 2,000 uses.
So antimicrobials-- Microban,
triclosan, triclocarban--
are in a vast number of
products in buildings.
They're in everything--
doorknobs, counters, seals,
walls.
But the fact is, they
don't provide a benefit.
They have huge
potential for harm.
They reach out of products.
They're not taken out by
sewage treatment plants,
so they end up in
our water supply.
They're one of the top
10 water contaminants.
They've been found to be
an endocrine disruptor.
And tragically, they're in
most women's breast milk,
which is not where you
want these chemicals.
And the fact is, once
again, we don't need them.
They're not needed.
And so again, purchasers
can pick products
without triclosan
and triclocarban.
And Google is really leading the
way in these kinds of efforts.
Consumer products-- cosmetics.
Because triclosan is actually
considered a pesticide,
it has to be labeled.
And so when you buy
things, you can look.
Colgate Total toothpaste--
0.05% triclosan.
I heard Crest is
advertising that it
doesn't contain triclosan,
so that's a good sign.
But when you're buying
personal care products,
you can just look on the label.
Cleaning products,
apparel-- all these products
you can choose with
and without triclosan.
So quickly, the other classes
I won't go into in much detail.
Bisphenols-- many of
you probably go out
of your way to get water bottles
that say bisphenol A free.
Anybody do that?
So I have a friend
who studies them,
a toxicologist at UC Davis,
who likes to shock people.
So he goes around
saying, I really
like my water bottle to say
it's got bisphenol A in it.
Because that way, I know it
doesn't have bisphenol S in it.
And the substitute
for bisphenol A
is often bisphenol S,
which he thinks is worse.
So with the class concept, we
don't want bisphenol A to Z.
Do you really need
something like bisphenol?
Do you need that function?
Is it worth it?
Is it necessary?
And if it's worth
it and necessary,
then let's really invest
in green chemistry
and come up with something
entirely different
that meets this function without
that potential for toxicity.
Similarly, thalates that also
helps soften plastics-- there's
a tendency to go from one
harmful thalate to the next.
So let's find green chemistry
solutions when we need it.
And in many cases,
let's not use it.
Solvents-- hydrocarbon
chlorinated oxygenated solvents
often are harmful.
Many times, you can use water.
One way to reduce
your own exposure
is to limit dry
cleaning, and when
you bring things back from the
dry cleaners, to air them out.
There's aqueous dry cleaning,
so you can use water instead.
And you can find
aqueous dry cleaners.
Well, we've known
for a long time
about the harm of these metals.
And still, there's
paints with led in them.
It's still worth checking
reducing the levels.
So what's happening?
Retailers are changing.
Many are selling furniture
without flame retardants.
Home Depot, Lowe's, and
Menard's are phasing out
thalates in flooring.
I got an email near
the middle of June
that made me really happy
from a major US retailer,
but I can't mention their name.
People don't like to mention.
And they said,
starting July 1, we're
not selling anything with flame
retardants or stain repellents.
We're not offering any
stain repellent treatments.
And this is a loss of
a profit center for us,
because we make money with these
stain repellent treatments,
but it's the right thing to do.
So if you go and try to get
a stain repellent treatment
and they won't sell
it to you, you'll
know this is the retailer.
IKEA is really the star.
This year, IKEA-- who we've been
working with for quite awhile--
said no fluorinated chemicals in
any of our products worldwide.
There are substitutes, they
said, for shower curtains,
raincoats, and umbrellas.
But they have a
nice table cloths
that needs grease resistance.
That doesn't exist without
fluorinated chemicals,
so they're going to stop selling
the tablecloth, which is pretty
principled and pretty neat.
And IKEA has been chemicals
in all of the six classes.
So based on all
that, we have come up
with a very bold statement.
We believe that the
use of some or all
of the six classes containing
chemicals of concern
can be reduced in consumer
products by 50% in five years.
And I think that's
possible just asking
the do you need it question.
IKEA has done this.
One large American
retailer has done it.
We're having a
meeting in December
with the commercial furniture
industry, the big companies,
and they're
interested in stopping
the use of all
antimicrobials, flame
retardants, and stain
repellents in office furniture.
That is a big deal.
And if they do, that's going
to really reduce the use.
So I'm really optimistic.
Our goal is to take good science
and use it for good policy.
And now I'm saying you
can use good science
for good purchasing and that
purchasing can be even more
powerful than policy.
So we send out
newsletters once a month
with updates on all of this.
If you'd like to be on our
e-newsletter list, in the back,
there please leave your
card or sign your name,
give me your card.
And I'm happy to
autograph books.
If you'd like a copy of
"Annapurna" or "Breaking
Trail," they're both here.
So I'm optimistic
that by reducing
the use of harmful
chemical classes,
we can all have a
healthier world.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So if there are any questions,
please come to the mics.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
So if I go to Whole Foods
and I go to the cleaning
isle and they all
these things that
say they're safe
and green, are they?
AUDIENCE: I look for triclosan.
I don't know.
Probably.
But I think it's good to take a
quick scan of the ingredients.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the C6 and the C8,
the chemicals that don't
break down in geological time.
Does that also make
them less reactive?
So would they be less
likely to cause harm
in biological,
chemical reactions?
ARLENE BLUM: That would be nice.
AUDIENCE: Or they
just don't know?
ARLENE BLUM: Right.
Unfortunately, they appear
to cause a lot of harm.
And the mechanisms
aren't so well known.
AUDIENCE: They might be
catalysts of something?
ARLENE BLUM: Yeah, or they
fit in, they fit into-- we
don't know why, but there
is this unique human epi
study of these 20,000
people who have been exposed
in southern Ohio
and West Virginia
where they came up with that
whole list of health problems
that's on the slide.
And in fact, that's what the
lawsuits today are starting.
So it's pretty unusual to have
that much human-- because all
these chemicals-- by the
way, to say the six classes,
the harm is irrefutable.
There are things like
genetically modified foods
are a real worry, but there's
not a lot of data to show harm.
What we went for
is the things where
there was no question of harm.
We didn't have to do
anymore experiments.
So the fluorinated chemicals
that have been studied,
there's vast numbers
of animal studies,
and then inadvertently, the very
sad, quote, human studies where
human populations are exposed
and you find human health
problems.
So I think the harm
from C8 is known.
From C6, there are 40 kinds.
It's going to be really
hard to prove things.
The fact that it ends up in
the brain is not a good sign.
And they are
biologically active.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
ARLENE BLUM: OK.
Well, I do hope that you
will sign our mailing list.
You can go to
greensciencepolicy.org
and click on
Fluorinated Chemicals
and learn more or
click on Six Classes
and learn about the six classes.
And as I said, if you
sign or mailing list,
or you can send me an email,
arlene@greensciencepolicy.org,
and we'll write you once
a month and update you
on what's happening.
I think saying in
five years, we're
going to reduce the
use of these chemicals
by 50% in consumer
products is a high goal.
But it feels to me
just like Annapurna.
That seemed pretty impossible,
one of the world's highest
mountain that had
never been climbed
by a woman or an American.
But we were able to get
the team together and reach
the summit of Annapurna.
And so to me, this
feels just the same.
A great team.
If you sign our mailing list,
you'll be part of the team,
working with scientists, people
in industry, government, NGOs.
And we all see the same summit.
It's a healthier world.
And I think moving step by step,
we can all achieve that goal.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]